- A few months back, we found
where we build a
car for under $500
and then we race over
the course of two days.
Danny agreed to
finance the team,
but finding a car for
under $500 is not easy.
Is that a puppy on a chain?
I don't see the chain.
I'm leery to walk
up and find out.
We didn't get a car,
but we did get a lemon.
Fortunately for us,
Shannon was able to resurrect
his old bomber car.
The guy's got it running again.
And then we used some
unconventional methods
to turn her into the
Count's Bloody Mess.
Today is race day.
These cars, they're awesome.
I don't know how
some of these cars
are going to end up
lasting this race.
Let's rock n' roll.
Get in there.
We may not last more than a
few laps before this thing
completely explodes.
But she sure as hell looks good.
Oh, yeah, boys.
To transform the bomber
into a race ready lemon,
first, we had to
get her running.
Then, make her safe,
so nobody dies.
Then came the fun part.
We made this car looks
like it's covered
with the blood and guts of an
unlucky herd of wild animals.
By covering her
with foam and red
paint to turn her into
Count's Bloody Mess.
All done, $500.
So who is racing first?
Shannon goes first?
Hell yeah.
We let Shannon go first.
Our goal should be
just finish the race.
Make it, and live.
Hey, we'd be lucky if
we finish this damn race.
Moment of truth, man, I'm the
captain, so I'm going first.
I'm excited but
a little nervous.
I haven't race this
thing in a while.
She didn't do so good back then.
And who knows what
mood she's in now?
They got the green flag.
Go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Man, look at him go.
- These tires are terrible.
- He's coming up.
There he is.
Go, go.
Look at that.
He's getting it.
Hey, hey, he's coming around.
Careful.
Oh, crap, this thing
drives like [beep]..
What is he doing out there?
Oh.
Off ramp.
Oh, no, I'm spinning out.
He's coming up, there he is.
Whoo.
Yes.
Over 300 laps, fellows.
And they were saying
we could only do 50.
Every hundred laps.
Hey, hey, and
Count's Bloody Mess.
All right, let's get started.
So before we get to the
winners, occasionally, Lemons
likes to award some losers.
So for the judges' choice,
these guys show up this weekend,
they had a great car,
somehow they kept
these terrible tires on it.
And, of course, it's the triple
nine, Count's Bloody Mess
from [inaudible].
Thank you.
- Well, done, man.
- Well done.
Hey, good job, man.
No way.
The guys and the car, they both
made it back from the Arizona
race this weekend.
I've got to say,
man, I'm impressed
that everybody's still alive.
I can't wait to
hear how it went.
I'm trying.
[laughter]
What's that?
Dramatic entrance there?
That's how I
make an exit, man.
- We took fourth place.
- In our class.
In our class.
22nd overall, but, hey.
- 22nd overall?
- Overall.
I didn't think you guys
were going to finish.
- Tada.
- What is this?
We got a trophy too.
And that's not a
participation trophy.
This was hands down the
scariest thing I've ever done
and at the same time
the time of my life.
- Really?
- Oh, my gosh.
It's been an
experience, for sure.
It was fun, huh?
You're fine when you're
doing it by yourself.
But then you've got
10 cars around you,
you're trying to--
oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
There is no where to go.
It is the most
frightening thing.
I'm extremely proud.
I'm so glad you guys are home.
On top of it all,
get back to work.
Let's go.
We've got work to do.
Everybody--
- Really?
We just got back.
We're still celebrating.
Everybody get your
butts back to work, man.
Man, I'm shocked this piece of
junk made it back in one piece.
And it lasted the whole weekend.
I'm glad the guys did well,
and they had a great time.
And now it's time for
me to have a little fun.
[laughter]
[inaudible]
I wanted to do that.
Ooh.
I think he's trying
to blow it up.
That's awesome.
He can't even blow it up.